welcome to the latest episode of just
getting started we've had an incredible
run here uh with this season on the
voices of the nfl starts with al
michaels and it should only be fitting
that it finishes right here
with my friend from nbc and also from
the nfl 100 all-time team show
chris collinsworth here on just getting
started how are you chris i'm good god
does that show seem like it was a
million years ago or what well the crazy
thing is is is that you know we're we're
recording this show right now just a
week after you and al
did the sunday night game of brady's
return to new england
and we saw
brady
and bill together in what wound up being
the spring right before their final
season together
and we were all like looking for any
symbol or sign or smoke signal of what
was going on because tom wasn't showing
up for his
otas and
you know and i just was going back and
forth with maybe they were uncomfortable
because it was the first segment we shot
of the entire six episode series and
bill hadn't done tv before but
that was an interesting run to say the
least chris yeah
you know and
the truth is always somewhere in between
right
you and i do a hundred thousand
interviews a year i think i did thirty
thousand today so i'm i
i feel like that sort of our job for
america is to sort of
slice it down right like i'm going to
talk to them to somebody and they're
going to give me some bs and then i'm
going to talk to that person they're
going to give me some bs i'm going to
talk to that person they're going to
give me some bs and
somewhere in between
lies the truth
and do we always get it right our
version of the truth
no i'm you know we don't
but
it's like it's a little like politics
you just have to try and do the best you
can
say what you know
offer an opinion say it's an opinion
and see how it goes
but i mean we're we're in a really
powerful position you know we talked to
i mean i i tried to break it down one
time when i was doing thursday nights
and sunday nights no i was there for
that i'm i'm in front of now they may be
the same people but probably
40 to 50 million people a week the
president of the united states isn't in
front of 50 million people a week you
know it's like maybe for a second or 30
seconds and believe me they're always a
lot smarter than i am too
but
it's like you build a relationship and
people know that you're gonna try and
give them
something honest and something that's
right without crossing lines or
embarrassing people on purpose but you
know we we work for whoever it is that's
watching not not the team
not the player not the quarterback not
the coach and so that's what we try to
get done and i know you do too i know i
feel the same way chris and you know i
had that front row seat for your double
dip years thursday nights and yeah and
saturdays you know when you you helped
launch thursday night football on
on nfl network and obviously you were
doing sunday nights on on on nbc and you
were with fox before all that and the
name of this podcast is just getting
started and i've been asking everybody
how they got started their careers and
obviously al as you might imagine had
quite a lot of stories to tell how did
you get started in the broadcasting
business chris
i honestly don't know i was
i mean right sometimes you choose it and
sometimes it chooses you
i was in law school when i
actually my final two years of playing
with the bengals
i got cut
i had just gotten married
and
literally 10 months thank god 10 months
after the wedding was the birth of our
first child so my wife was pregnant
uh holly
and
so i'm so i'm cut and i'm going
hey looks like i'm going to be a lawyer
okay no big deal
and then i got a call from
rick bernstein and ross greenberg at hbo
and they said would you like to do
features on inside the nfl
and i said well how much does it pay
and they said fifty thousand dollars
and i said
the answer is yes
now tell me what's a feature and
i didn't know i didn't know what they
wanted me to do i thought you know
because they had asked me during my
career
to go on and be interviewed they had
asked me to do like a christmas
scene thing where i read some
silly
you know
i don't know stories on the air
and nick boniconi and i used to go on
there and fight all the time and and
i guess somewhere along the line they go
well that was good and i go okay
and so then i traveled the country and i
was i was doing these features well
about
with that within a week
bob trumpy decided that he wanted to cut
back at wlw radio
and because he was the number one
broadcaster on nbc
so he cut back on his nights on the
radio so they said would you like to
come in and
fill in when he can't do it
and i oh how much does it pay you know i
mean that's all we all do sure and and
so i i was like okay i took that job
and then and i'm still in law school and
then
at later in the year dick eversol
because they need garbage broadcasters
right they need guys to do
the bottom end game so
four times a year they have games that
only go to one city that it's they're so
the games are so bad
it's never sold out in the one city and
then so it's only broadcast and i don't
know if you've ever seen it but they
have
at nbc they would have this map of the
united states sure
and on it they would have stars you know
they'd have green stars for the cowboys
and it would take up three quarters of
the country they'd have you know red
stars for the washington football team
and then they'd have blue stars for
those and then they would have one star
for the game that i did because that
meant it was only going to one tiny
little market in the middle of the
country
and so i'm like well i should just do
the game like i'd like to say hi to
george down at the hardware store you
know because it's like only a handful of
people are going to be watching and you
can't imagine how much trouble i got in
just being in one market
because when you're doing talk radio
you got to be crazy to just survive like
you got to throw out junk to stir up the
pot and get people to call in and all
that kind of stuff so what i knew about
broadcasting was doing talk radio so i'm
i'm throwing out heaters left and right
on these games oh my i was so bad
no you're definitely not bad i was
wondering like
instead of a star it would be a bottle
of milk because like that's what they're
milk games it's two percent of the
country one percent of the country like
they're those are the that's that's the
audience you're getting but who so
who was doing the play-by-play who are
you hooked up with for your first game
broadcast a guy named jim donovan you
know jim sure the name he's in cleveland
he does the local news and he does the
games on radio for them and it was a
game in cleveland and so he knew
everything about the browns
and i thought so david michaels is my
producer
and so david comes in to the room and on
saturday night and he said
what are you going to do how are you
going to do this actually it's on friday
night it was on friday afternoon
so how you how are you going to do this
and i had like what are they called
manila envelopes you know that you like
little folders and yeah yeah so i i was
i was
i said well i'm just gonna write the
names on this thing
and i thought i was way ahead of the
curve right
like i'm gonna blow him away
i'm actually gonna write down the names
and numbers of these guys
on this little folding thing
and david is only david can do which i
love david he was like
oh my god
i can still i can still remember his
face
so he used to work with terry bradshaw
and doing games
and
he goes listen this is going to be a
train wreck i can't believe they gave me
you
and but we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna make this work so he calls terry
and he said terry
you know those boards that you've had
made up and they were like this big yeah
to put all the things in there he goes
can you just fedex me one of those i i'm
gonna i'm gonna try and help a guy
that's gonna have the shortest
broadcasting career
but let's see if we can get him through
this game because i don't want to ruin
my career too
bro okay so he sends it out and i write
all the names and the bigger things and
he tells me you know you should take
little notes and here's things you could
talk about and they gave me some
newspaper now remember this is like in
90
in 89 in 89. and so
literally there's no internet there's no
you know now i i couldn't get through
all the information and film that i have
now if i never slept and worked on this
24 hours a day all year long
because it's just it's everywhere
there's information everywhere and pff
has quadrupled my life with information
i bet
and so you know we finally get out and i
go do the game
and i i think i'm just literally
brilliant by the time i get off the air
and we come back and a few weeks later
the same team comes back and does it
again and they're all having breakfast
at the local ihop or whatever so i go
down and meet him and i've got a big
smile on my face and i was like thinking
they were gonna tell me how great i was
and uh and then they they go walking in
and they said i said what are you guys
doing he goes oh we're just talking
about the game we all felt like we did a
really good job
and and then there was you
and i go
really
and he goes yeah and they started
proceeding to tell me everything
in the world i'd ever done wrong i mean
it was like
wow
i literally thought that i was gonna i
wasn't sure i was gonna make it through
the four games that ever saw sign before
i mean it really was like that
and uh but they didn't want to hire
anybody else
and or nobody else would accept what
they were paying me is probably more
like it i swear to you we did a game we
did a game on the west coast one time
the my flight the ticket to get me to
the game was more than i was making
doing the game
i was like
can i just do it from the house and cash
this sucker in i go i just swear i'll
talk loudly i'll do the whole thing
[Music]
hey when was the last time you seriously
considered your dream i mean come on you
used to think about it all the time what
happened
i say it's time you and your dream get
back together think about it you could
live the van life and a totally
customized mercedes-benz sprinter you
could tour around all 423 national park
sites build a mountain cabin with your
dad or start your own business really
whatever you dream up and it's a
mercedes-benz van we're talking about so
expect innovative safety features like
crosswind assist and blind spot assist
expect amazing performance and
reliability with an mbux voice command
system a five-star dealer network and an
available gas engine it runs like well a
dream so what do you say head to the
mercedes-benz van dealership and get
that sprinter tell them your dream sent
you
[Applause]
so did you
like at some point think that this
wasn't gonna work or and you were just
doing it just to see where it was going
i mean like is that
where like is there a point where
you know you thought it wasn't gonna
happen oh yeah oh for sure and and the
the radio in many ways i i sort of
marvel at people that are really good on
the radio
the radio in many ways was the hardest
thing i was doing
[Music]
because you're
in a local market you're talking about
the reds or the bengals or the bearcats
or xavier university or whatever
and
i've got a wife and kids and three other
jobs and going to law school so it
wasn't like i could sit around and watch
every game that was played and no
internet so there was no there was no
faking it at that point you get exposed
and then they started wanting me to read
these 60 second commercials live on the
air which sounds really easy when
somebody like you doesn't it sounds
really easy
and i'm on there and i'm screwing this
stuff up so badly and i'm getting now
i'm starting to get nervous doing them
now my voice is shaking while i'm trying
to do them and it's just you and a
microphone right and this and trumpy had
created this monster audience
out there
and and i i mean it was i i think i even
told hollywood i go listen
i hope i'm a better lawyer than i am a
broadcaster this is not going to last
very long i might be able to fake my way
through like the features and
some of that stuff but this is really
hard this is really hard
and um
you know somehow i'm still doing this
like whatever it is
30 something years later i mean it's un
it's i mean i you could not start lower
on the totem pole than where i was you
there is no way you can start lower well
it takes hard work to get up that ladder
and determination and obviously you kept
doing it so when did you uh tap out of
law school when did things kind of turn
where it's like okay
um let's just leave the lawyer stuff
aside and let's keep following
the broadcasting when did that happen
well i i graduated in
91 because i could only go part time
um it took me five years to get through
there wow they offered me tenure when i
left which i thought was only
appropriate
and
i i so i'm i'm literally i'm a part of
every graduating class but i wasn't
graduating you know like so i i knew
everybody
in the school and of course they knew me
because i used to play the bengals and
so it was just
like you know i'd get in a class and
they'd make me debate somebody in a you
know some debate over a case and i'm you
know by then i'm doing talk radios
firing stupid stuff out but you know
having fun
but i really thought and i told holly
this multiple times i go listen
this is going to last a year you know
and then the next quarterback's going to
come out and then they're going to take
my place and then uh you know i'll go
back and i'll be a lawyer well it lasted
for two years
and so then when i graduated
i literally couldn't sit for the bar
exam because you've got to take like at
least three or four months and just go
cram
and study and so either the cram and
study was during the middle of football
season when i was doing all this stuff
but by then i was doing more games uh or
it was at the beginning of the year
where i just couldn't do it it was in
football season
um
so i never did i always thought that
there was going to come a time when i
would just literally
go thank you very much shake everybody's
hand and go back and be an attorney and
i just never did i it's as stunning to
me as it is to anybody else i really
swear to you
and part of me still feels that way a
little bit that i i'm not going to be
able to pass the bar but you know maybe
i can find somebody to take it for me i
don't know you know we'll figure
something out
so
kosel's not the only guy with a law
degree that al michaels has worked with
is basically what you're saying i had no
idea you actually have a law degree no
law degree but uh but i'm not a lawyer
so okay that's that kind of it's like i
have an accounting degree
but i'm not i've never been an
accountant so go figure all this then
you wound up in the booth with joe and
joe bach and aikman right like is that
that's was that yeah that was a big
break later though because is that the
big break for you pretty much
actually tom hammond was a big break for
me
and i don't know how many people know
about tom ham but i love tom hammond tom
hammond taught me more about
broadcasting than any human being alive
and our big break again came when trump
didn't want to work
trump trump he decided that he did not
want to do the orange bowl and by this
time i'm doing notre dame games
and trumpy decided that they wanted to
do the nfl playoff game instead of the
orange pool so they asked us to do the
orange bowl and it was for the national
championship
and
[Music]
so i was like okay great and it's miami
and nebraska
and we go down and the night before the
game tommy roy do you know tommy the
producer at nbc produces golf he just
fantastic guy fantastic guy and tommy
decides that since we've been doing some
college football but i was mostly nfl
that they really need to
get the referees
in and have us talk about
the difference between nfl rules and
college rules right
so i was like great fantastic so this
ends up being like an hour-long meeting
i wish i could name the officials i
can't
um but they were great and they they
really were very good at explaining the
differences of what they were
so we get into the national championship
game and
i swear to you rich like eight of these
things came up like happened in the
freaking game
and so as soon as they came up i'm like
well yeah if the guard pulls out and
then he does this thing and that's
illegal and you can't do it now wouldn't
be illegal in the nfl sound like a
genius you know and i'm literally just
regurgitating
what happened the night before so there
were a couple of articles written the
next day
about
you know wow this guy really is honestly
smart he knows exactly what you know one
of those kind of things
and i'm like tommy if you had not called
those referees
there's no way i would have known any of
that stuff so you know it's funny and
that you probably have a thousand people
in your life like this too
it's like there are people along the way
that
nobody is ever going to know it
you know david michaels nobody knew that
he got that board from terry bradshaw
tom hammond
wore me out
about anything i was doing wrong or any
you know but was just a fantastic
teacher of the business tommy roy comes
up with this
unbelievable bringing the referees in
and teaching it so
a lot of times okay i i work hard at it
i really do i try my best to to
you know
the everybody else in the world works
all week i might work all week so that
they don't have to and i'll try and help
them watch the game that's that's the
way i look at it that is great chris but
it takes luck you know rich it takes
luck along the way
to just
string together to come from the eighth
broadcast team at the bottom
and have a career as long as i've had
it's like thank god i have no idea
[Music]
on the football field everyone has to
play by the rule book shouldn't it be
that way off the field too following a
law enacted at the start of 2021
hospitals have a new set of rules they
need to play by to provide clear and
upfront pricing to patients and unlike a
wide receiver dragging their feet to
stay inbounds hospitals are dragging
their feet to stay out of bounds not
complying with new federal rules for
price transparency help spread the word
to make sure hospitals don't break the
rules because when they do patients will
always lose sponsored by power to the
patients
[Applause]
well i'll share this with you chris so
at nfl network
you know which we launched in o3
and we
we we we turn the lights on week 11 2003
and you know we all hope that this is
going to work out you know and we all
believe like it's a very calculated risk
bet
certainly since i'm leaving espn and i'm
i'm going there and all of us there were
just like
just trying to put one foot in front of
the other and build something and build
something and build something and
rumor has it in
2005
that the league is going to restart
thursday night football and put it on
nfl network which was huge
for us
and
the first thought i had
was to walk into steve bornstein's
office
who's my rabbi he was smart enough to
hire me twice at espn then an nfl
network because a dream of mine is to
call play-by-play in football with
regularity i mean everybody in studio
wants to be at the games a lot of people
in the games want to be in studio that's
kind of you're already nodding your head
that's that's the way things work in our
business so anyway i'll go into steve's
office and i tell them
you know uh if we're going to get the
football package i would like to call
the football games and he says to me not
a chance and i'm like what do you mean
not a chance do you not believe in me he
goes
richie boyd it's always richie boy i
believe in everything you can do that's
why you're here you're one of the best
at doing what i hired you to do
you're not
gonna be leaving the studio because if i
i need you to host the pre and the
halftime because if i put you in the
booth i gotta hire somebody else for
that and i'm like who are you gonna hire
then they do the games he goes i don't
know who's calling the games all i know
always doing the play-by-play all i know
is who i want is my analyst and i'm like
who and he says there's only one guy
and it was you and he goes that's and
i'm like i i'm like nodded my head and
he goes there's no one else
in the business that he said that would
be even considerate
it was you
and the fact that you did the games
chris
was so huge and obviously bryant gumbel
for crying out loud calling the game
by the way oh my gosh i mean but for us
at the network where we were just
putting one foot in front of the other
the fact that someone of your caliber
and obviously bryant's as well
would say you know what we'll we'll
we'll put our brand on nfl networks and
go for it it meant so much to us but i
wanted to share with you bornstein was
like i don't know who's calling the
games i know it's not you and i know who
the analyst is it's going to be
collinsworth well i know why he hired
you so many times because
you can't say no to that man
she came down to orlando florida my
parents
were there at dinner with me and it's
steve and my mom and dad and me
at christine he's in orlando if you've
never been there it's a great place
and
and he launches into this sales pitch
you would have thought
i was some combination of
jfk and jesus christ
like he's on my he's recruiting my mom
more than he is me
and i've never heard i've never heard a
sales pitch
like this in my whole life and i'm like
steve come on man
what are you doing this is like you're
out of your mind i mean he just would he
was relentless
on this thing
um but you couldn't say no to him i mean
at the end of the day i'm like god how
did i say no to that you know i mean it
was it was unbelievable so but it was
fun you know i mean bryant
and
you know people are going to nitpick and
do his thing and the only reason i know
is because i actually tried to do
play-by-play at one time i don't know if
you know this story no
so
there was a time when they wanted
john madden to do the games
and i'm in the studio
and they they always sort of had this
stream that really two analysts do in
the games
and so i would sort of do the
play-by-play and john would be the
caller but it would be much more of like
a conversation
about football than like a traditional
broadcast so we're like peyton and eli i
guess right now everybody's trying to
reinvent the wheel you know
and and so
they flew this was all time so they fly
a freaking
jumbo jet
747 with two bedrooms in this freaking
thing
across the country they take the whole
nbc sports team
to john madden's studios ever been in
john's studios i've heard it's like it's
it's all the time i've i've heard it's
it's like the the uh the skywalker ranch
of sports is what oh it's unbelievable
plus in pleasanton i think that's the
right name yeah he owns the town like he
bought the town yeah he owns the town
literally i'll tell you that's the thing
and there's not like a mcdonald's or a
starbucks like everything's a
mom-and-pop thing like he created his
own
personal heaven right
and so we go in to do this game and i'm
i'm doing the play-by-play
and i'm sort of like how hard can it be
how hard can it be
so but i started doing some practice
games before that
and so they put a microphone on me and
and
um you know we had all merrell hodge
came and we had like a corner of the
booth and they would record them and
that we would call the games
well
i couldn't undo what i had learned to do
my whole life like when i broadcast the
game i don't watch the football
i
i a lot of a lot of times i lose where
it is because i think al's job is to
tell you what's happening to the
football and my job is to tell you
something you didn't see so if i'm
watching the football i'm telling you
the same thing
that al told you and that you already
saw on tv so i'm watching everything but
so when i'm trying to do play-by-play
now i've got to watch the football and
i i didn't really know like like
just getting on the air
hello everybody how are you here in
kansas city and dinner this team's that
and then it seems that and you know
that's a lot harder than you think it is
just opening your show every week people
don't appreciate and then the transition
when somebody's talking in your ear and
saying all right it's time for
commercial down and seven
six and i'm trying to go and i'm going
we're gonna be right back i'm like i'm
like a dancer i'm like going with the
beat of the music you know i'm like i i
mean i literally i go this is so god
darn hard and finally ever saw comes out
at the end of the first quarter he goes
what are you doing
and i
like i'm just surviving because stop
trying to be
the play-by-play guy just talk to john
in football just talk football to him
and so we go back in and and we did and
we just started having like a
conversation but probably a little bit
more like peyton and eli kind of thing
and then i would know you know a guy's
name or i would do it just play a little
bit of adam
so at the end of this this
you know wild ride we go back and and so
now everybody's going to have a little
debrief and we're going to talk about
all this stuff
and
so dick comes back and he goes it goes
listen i want you to know
if you want this job at yours
you got me
if you want this job it's yours
okay
he said but
i have a chance now to get out michael's
i said what are you stupid
what are you stupid i go
get the hell out of here let's take the
jet and go get out i go
are you are you crazy i go you're gonna
do me over oh michael's i go i would i
would never do that to you
and so that's when they did the whole
deal and they came down you know
and they in some ways i think that
and not that anybody would ever admit i
was like was i the leverage
for al michaels
did i cost al like a couple of million
dollars because in his mind there was at
least a possibility
that i could have been the play-by-play
guy if he just sat in the room and
watched me be played by a plate guy he
would have tripled his price instead of
taking some reduction in it so
there you go actually i think chris
oswald the rabbit was the leverage in
that trade that they made
[Music]
they made the trade
foreign did you see it
i did not it's uh it's definitely a
disney character i never thought i'd
know about until al was traded for it
you know rich look it up
all right you want my conspiracy theory
on that one okay sure
i love these things anyway
so oswald the rabbit let me just
describe oswald the rabbit so for people
who don't know it was everybody thought
it was like a joke it was like a throw
in al michaels got traded for this
little cartoon character oswald around
yeah from disney to nbc for sunday night
football
keyword disney to nbc so disney
is built around one character right
mickey mouse built around one care
the predecessor to mickey mouse
was oswald the rabbit
and oswald the rabbit
is the same head the same eyes the same
everything only he's got long ears he's
got rabbit ears but other than that
other than mouse ears versus long ears
it is mickey mouse i'm telling you look
it up
and i i'm thinking and you know with my
massive legal training of five years yes
i'm thinking some lawyer has his entire
life sat in the back room and gone
if somebody really wanted to push
right if somebody really wanted to
challenge this
you could get in front of a jury and go
you know what
whoever owns oswald the rabbit
really owns disney world you know i go
you know because this is really this
started mickey mouse and mickey mouse
wasn't the first character mickey mouse
was the second character and that means
that nbc now owns disney world and
everything that goes with it now that's
ridiculous but i guarantee there was
some warrior that said
i don't know how we're gonna get this
yeah we gotta button this up but we need
to get that rabbit back at some point
well there you go that's my concern oh
michael this was the way to button that
up they got to close their back door to
lose
disney world that is amazing i had no
idea that the idea before maybe even now
coming was was you and and madden
together but that's dick ebersole man
you're you're so fortunate to be exposed
to so many incredible people in this
business and he's obviously
at the top of that list man no human
being
i'm not even sure yeah my parents would
be above that my wife would be above
that but no human being outside of my
family
impacted my life like him there's not a
chance when i was at fox
um i had another year left on my
contract and he came along and he said
this is we i work for nbc
they lost football i went to fox i did
the studio for a while with terry and
howie and those guys and then i went and
did games with joe and troy and i loved
all of it
um
and
but then nbc got football back
and actually dick was the one that
recommended to me and fox knew it so i
could have gone to cbs or fox at the
time
um and
and dick told me he goes and i was gonna
go to cbs because it was like a startup
show and i said well i can they can
build it around me these guys are
already established and he said no he
goes he goes chris you to go to fox and
i said why do i have to go to fox
he said you're very good at
football and breaking it down and
serious and you're
edgy and you're all those things
he said they're going to teach you how
to have fun with broadcasting they're
going to teach you that
broadcasting is more than
just the game it's it's a story it's a
it's it's a
sense of humor it's all those things
it's a welcome into my home
you would feel comfortable with me on
your couch like you would terry bradshaw
or hallie long or jb or one of those
guys
and i thought about it a long time and i
said
okay because i was definitely going to
be the fourth wheel
on that show as opposed to the first
wheel
on the other but i'm really so glad that
i did i it was it was i learned a lot
but then at the end of that
when he got football back
he came to me and he said
i want you back
you got to come back to nbc
and so i went to the guys at fox and i
said
you know i really would like to go back
if if i can nothing personal but you
know this is a great opportunity
and um
and
ed goran flew out to
see
me um
and
so he was gonna make in an offer and
nbc had already made
an offer an unbelievable offer at the
time
um
and so he was sitting i was coaching a
little league baseball game that night
and so he unbeknownst to me he loves
little league baseball he loves him
and
so he was so excited so i've got a hell
of a team we ended up winning like the
whole cincinnati
freaking i built a batting cage at my
house i'm like i was so over the top it
was ridiculous
so i've i've always been talking about
my team we've just kicked everybody's
butt
and then he comes to a game i swear to
you we're down 8-1 going into the last
setting i'm out of my mind i don't care
about ed dorn i don't care about fox i
don't care about football i don't care
about broadcasting i'm literally out of
my mind we we're kicking the ball around
we're so bad this day i'm like i was
embarrassed and the whole time now ed's
trying to tell me what i'm doing wrong
coaching and how he could what i should
be doing you know and so i'm now i'm
even crazier
we come back and score eight runs in the
bottom of get out i think it was
win the game
we go out to dinner we're drinking like
we just won the world series having the
biggest time of all time
and and that was but it was the end of
my fox days because i said this is what
they want to do with me this is what
they're willing to pay me and he goes
i won't get in the way of that i won't
get no because congratulations so
he's another prince too ed gordon no
doubt about it we had nance on earlier
and he he sung at goran's praises so
much and because ed was on cbs before he
went to fox and it's amazing how you
know it's it's an industry where where
we all know one another
so to wrap this up i've been i'll ask
you uh what i've been asking everybody
is the final question uh throughout this
series is is what's the best piece of
advice you've received chris in your
career and from who what would you say
is the best piece of advice is the final
question here for you
um wow that's a really good question
um
it came i i'm going to give this guy
credit for something because it was it
was hard to say this to me
um i was at wimbledon we were covering
wimbledon for hbo
and
so and i was always kind of the you know
when i what do i know about wimbledon so
we were always kind of the goof around
film crew doing features around
wimbledon and all that kind of stuff
so
one day it was like literally the fourth
day of cancelled tennis
because of rain i mean it was like it
was awful everywhere it was just awful
poured the whole time no matches so they
got to create programming around crap
you know they're you you've done it
before i've done it before it's like you
know you're in a 57 to nothing game like
all right we're talk radio here we go
and and so they said go out and do a
rain feature
what i'll do a feature on the rain
so i end up creating this whole scenario
and don't even ask me about this
but
the in the punch line of the whole thing
was they had like a parking lot that
went down a hill
and it's as muddy as you can possibly
imagine so i've got on a coat and tie
and i'm doing this whole formal thing
and at the end of it i run and i jump
and i do a mudslide literally
to the bottom of the hill sure i got mud
freaking everywhere people saw it
they're cracking up
and and uh as a matter of fact billy
packer one time told me he goes
i was walking through the airport
against chris and i was so late for a
flight i just got to give him the yo you
know kind of thing and i was like yeah
and now look i was like oh billy how you
doing so i said i'll stop you and he
goes i got to tell you a story because i
know you're in a hurry i'll tell you a
story he said every year my family loves
tennis we watch tennis all the time we
love tennis
he goes every year at thanksgiving when
we all get together there's only one
tradition that we have
one tradition i swear to you this is
true
every year my family pulls out the tape
of you doing the mudslide at wimbledon
it is like our common bond we watch it i
go get out of here because i'm telling
you the truth we watch that every single
year that we do that
so anyway so it
sounds like it was a great thing and a
lot of fun
ross greenberg at the end of the thing
he comes back
and he calls me in his office
and he said
chris he goes
i understand why you did the feature the
way you did
because i think you have a chance to be
really good in this business
and
he said but
you don't want to be the clown
i mean it's okay to be funny or try to
be funny
but you don't want to be the clown you
want to be the one that's taken
seriously
and
it's way easier to try and be the clown
you know i mean it's more fun it's like
this it's like but there are some people
that are born to do that terry bradshaw
was born to make human beings laugh you
know not and he just so happened to win
four super bowls along the way but he
was born to make people laugh
and
and i
i can't tell you how many times that has
rung in my head
over the years
that you just go
you know there's way more people that
are
that want something smart than they you
know they want a bad comedian to try and
make them laugh there's a lot of people
trying to do that out there on
television
and i just so i thought that was i
thought it was really good i thought it
was hard for him to do it to me but i
thought it was heartfelt and it was it
really served me well
chris you're the man i really appreciate
the time um congrats on um you know pff
being an amazing success with under your
stewardship congrats on your son and his
career as it's going i mean that's got
to be an immense amount of pleasure for
you and holly and everyone else in your
family and congrats on everything i
appreciate your your friendship and
joining this pot truly you're my pal man
do anything for you thanks chris
collinsworth thank you that's chris
collinsworth right here on just getting
started
[Music]
today's episode of just getting started
is brought to you by geico do you own or
rent your home of course you do and i
bet it can be hard work you know what's
easy bundling policies with geico geico
makes it easy to bundle your homeowners
or renters insurance along with your
auto policy it's a good thing too
because you already have so much to do
around your home go to geico.com get a
quote and see how much you could save
it's geico easy visit geico.com today
that's geico.com
[Applause]
well that wraps up the final
conversation of this 10-part series of
just getting started on
the origin stories of voices of the nfl
and this has been um
a labor of love man there's just no
other way to put it and
uh like i said i've known chris since he
started calling the games for nfl
network in 2006 on thursday night
football with brian gumbel
and you know i know he was
talking about how difficult it was to
call play-by-play it was bryant gumbel's
you know his brother greg
is still a voice of the nfl on
cbs and uh someone who's called several
super bowls for cbs but bryant was not
known for play-by-play at all if brian
gumbel's known for anything
and he should be and is in certain parts
of this
industry of the nfl it was for the
pregame show that he hosted on nbc
while
the nfl today on cbs with brent
mussberger was creating
sports tv history in its own right
and bryant gumbel's one of the first
voices of the nfl so for him to come
out of his if you will
lane
being
the real sports anchor
and
former today show anchor and somebody
not associated with calling down in
distances for him to do that
certainly for the nfl network was
monstrously big for us at the nfl
network which
you know at the time
and this was always something that
bothered me and still does and bothers
all of us at the nfl network that we're
not allowed to have our own voice that
the man the nfl will not allow us
to speak about
coaches decisions being wrong and
referees making the wrong call or owners
hiring the wrong coach or
so on and so forth
so
you know there was a big question that
when collinsworth was going to be
calling these games with somebody that
whoever was calling the games
would have
an un be smurchable resume
that would never in a million years
be thought to be
a mouthpiece for the nfl and parrot a
company line and not call
it as he sees it
so for brian gumbel to say i'll call
those games
was huge for us huge and i love getting
to meet him i'll never forget as
you know
chris collinsworth said he was doing two
a week thursday night for nfl network
and sunday night for
for
nbc and
when he was doing the games on thursday
night he was doing the
the studio show initially for nbc before
madden retired and he went up into the
booth with al and i had no idea by the
way that the first thought that nbc
would go with
uh for sunday night football was madden
and collinsworth together
and then you know al michaels popped
free and he went with al michael's dick
ever so i'd never heard that story
but for for for chris
and
for bryant bryant would call the
thursday game and then chris would leave
to do the sunday
nbc
we would do in the first couple years of
nfl network it wasn't just thursday not
only it was thursday saturday it was the
the package would start on thanksgiving
night right now it's all season long but
when it started in 2006 it was
thanksgiving night
was when it would start and then there
would be a saturday game right after the
whole concept was a run-up to the
playoffs package on nfl network that hey
cable networks and cable operators that
wouldn't get nfl network you're missing
out and your subscribers are going to
miss out and those are those cable
war days for nfl network that caused me
to lose some of this up here
but we would do
thursday saturdays and chris would go do
the nbc stuff and we would have i think
dick vermeel called a few saturday games
and we had a just a rotating analyst
that chris would chris would sometimes
call a saturday game two and then go
overnight to nbc on a sunday so chris
would sometimes do three in a week but
sometimes it was just
um
uh bryant and dick vermeel or bryant and
someone else
anyway the reason why i'm telling you
this story is from a thursday night one
time i'll never forget this thursday
night we were in st louis
it was the night fast willie parker
actually broke his leg and his career
kind of changed after that was st louis
and pittsburgh and then we flew to
carolina
for carolina and i forget who caroline
was playing in that game
and we're on an overnight charter flight
and it's it's late man i mean it's like
one in the morning where wheels up
and brian's got a call a game in two
days and he takes out his boards as
chris just mentioned
what you have in front of you
isn't just a manila envelope that you
open up and you know a folder a little
folder that you open up and scribble
names on it's just this beautiful big
board with names and stats and numbers
and what have you that is laid out like
an nfl team is so the defensive line is
here and the linebackers are here and
the cornerbacks are here and then you
flip it over and the offensive line is
here and the quarterback is here and the
running back's there and the wide outs
are here it looks like an actual
you know
play for an nfl lineup on the field at
any rate
he takes those boards out bryant and
then
a red double a red duffel bag and i'm
sitting right across from him
and i'm thinking i gotta get some sleep
i mean we're not gonna get into carolina
until
three in the morning and then we got a
meeting the next day and it's just tough
but i need to get some rest but if
brian's staying up maybe i should do
some studying too
and brian takes out this red
duffel bag
calls over the flight attendant and asks
for orange
juice okay
what's bryan up to
as the orange juice is being brought to
him he unzips the red duffel bag and
inside
is a monster
fifth of vodka and he turns to me he
goes you want a screwdriver
[Music]
and all my pride gumbel is offering me a
screwdriver
made from orange juice from the flight
attendant and from this craft service
here in the plane
and
from a fifth of vodka that he brought on
the plane and a red zip zipped up duffel
bag
hell yeah i'm gonna have a screwdriver
with brian gumbel and we did
yeah just it was not like we didn't get
hammered it wasn't the whole i guess
that was the only thing that was
available that he could purchase was
this big
bottle of vodka but he just poured a
drink and just anybody else want one
couldn't have been more just cool and
chill
brian freaking gumble colin games and it
just that story kind of came to light
with chris telling his story and
uh you know i just love these stories
that you hear on this podcast of so many
people in our business
that uh you've heard names mentioned by
many people
um same names because our industry the
television industry the broadcasting
industry it's a it's a small community
and that's one thing that i learned when
i
you know was at northwestern middle
school of journalism it's like it's it's
it's a small community and you've got to
be great to everyone that you meet not
only because that's what the human being
thinks to do but
you need to you need to make sure that
the people that you meet
on day one
uh you treat with respect because on day
1000 and year 20 they might be running a
network or they're going to hear about
the way you talk to other people or
handle your business it's a small
world but it's a team world
where producers behind the scenes
make things go
and make the job of the people that you
hear and see on television or on the
radio or wherever you take in your shows
that they are broadcasting in a manner
that brings an entire
show and game together
directors camera
operators
stats
everybody who works behind the scenes in
the trucks around the production trucks
in operations and travel and
so on and so forth it's a huge operation
and everybody needs a break and
everybody needs some luck but it also
requires on-air
a very very
very strenuous work ethic
in order to succeed and you also have to
have
a gumption
so i have been
asking everyone
what's the best piece of advices
advice that they've received
i'm going to leave anybody who's if
you've taken in this podcast because
it's something that you want to learn
from because you want to get in this
business that's the whole idea of just
getting started the reason why it was
created is to give you the
listener or if you're watching on my
youtube channel rich eisenhower youtube
channel
the viewer to give you something
portable to take away
so you can
use something as you just get started in
your new
business new venture if you want to try
something something portable well this
being just a specific 10-part series on
voices of the nfl and very broadcast
television broadcast
sports television broadcast heavy
i'll leave you with two pieces of advice
that i give to people when they ask me
for mine
and the first is never take no for an
answer
don't
if somebody tells you no don't take it
personally and don't take it
for an answer you have no idea if
they've had a bad day
you don't have any idea if they've had a
bad day woke up on the wrong side of the
bed and was just being mean
honestly i've had people just mean to me
trying to get ahead in this business
trying to get started in the business
they were just mean flat-out mean
um
they also might not have had a job
right then and there
it's nothing personal sometimes it could
have been i don't know
but just don't take no for an answer
just because you're told no right now
does not mean you're not good enough to
be in this business
you just have to try
harder you got to try again
you've got to try a different way
to try harder or a different way to try
again
and there's so many different ways for
you to get started in this business as
opposed to when i got started there was
no youtube
there was no
i mean the internet was truly just
getting started to use that phrase
there was no internet there was no
podcasts there was no way to do it
yourself
and that's the other thing that i want
to leave you with this is the mantra i
tell all
my
colleagues
on the rich eisen shows we've just had
to get started on my show again i mean
in 2019 we were told we were done by att
and we just got started on something new
we just put our notes to grindstone i
would not take no for an answer and then
here's the other the other um
uh axiom piece of advice is if not
you then who
and if not now
when
it's got to be you
you have to be the one to make your
break
and if not
now
then when are you going to try it so do
it
just do it don't listen to doubts don't
listen to
anyone who tells you about how long the
odds are i mean just think about how
many breaks
that you heard during these 10
episodes that you heard that were luck
but also self-made gymnasts
deciding to knock on the door of an nbc
truck of don olmeyer and ask for him
don olmeyer was as big a producer in
this business as ever been
as he was at the time when jim nance a
university of houston
student decided to knock on his door
you know
kevin harlan a 19-year-old
producer of the chiefs radio pregame
show
while he's a student at the university
of kansas decides to write a note
to john fasenda nfl film saying hey
would you mind voicing the show open of
my
of my
local radio show and fasenda did it
you know
if not him then who and if not at that
time then when are you going to try it
so
don't take no for an answer and if not
you who
and if not now when
those are my two pieces of advice for
anybody out there
thanks for taking in this uh this
10-part series of just getting started
it's been a labor of love
check out all the episodes previous to
this one with chris collinsworth who i
thank and i want to thank everybody else
for
putting this
all together
i want to thank my producer lou
pellegrino and robert barowski
along with sarah mccrory putting these
shows together i want to thank you guys
thank you
uh teresa gage and her hard work and
crew
to
make sure that all the sponsors are
happy
and i want to thank you for taking it in
so
appreciate you
listening to just getting started and
we'll see you next time
you